welcome back to New rockstars I'm Eric
Boss and as we look ahead for more kind
of forever new Phase 5 titles like
secret evasion Thunderbolts Captain
America new world order the real New
World Order of the MCU has finally been
confirmed with the clearest sense of the
actual political hierarchy of this
universe we've gotten yet and like all
hierarchies how it's gonna be toppled
into chaos and succession crises when it
comes to power on Earth right now who's
actually running this [ __ ] and is there
a conspiratorial plot to replace them as
the Multiverse consumes us all will the
war on the ground be a proxy Shadow war
between the squirrel Empire and the
Intelligentsia with mankind caught in
the crossfire in the past the MCU has
largely avoided the political hierarchy
of Earth the Iron Man films introduced
characters like Senator Stern whom
Captain America Winter Soldier revealed
was part of Hydra along with many of the
rank and violin Shield Iron Man 3
introduced president Matthew Ellis
played by William Sadler and his vice
president Rodriguez who had been
corrupted by aim and Aldrich Killian
president Ellis remained U.S president
in the MCU up through 2016. as Captain
America Civil War whih promo shorts
included president is talking about the
Lagos incident and appointing that is
for us to be Secretary of State Ross
remains Secretary of State during Civil
War and during the events of the Black
Widow film that takes place right after
Civil War but after the after the blit
political power on Earth was changed we
have new agencies like sword focusing on
other worldly threats probably led by
Abigail brand as in the comics which
might be Emilia Clarke's character in
secret Invasion or maybe soon led by
Nick Fury based on footage of him I saw
at d23 on a sword space station there
are also agencies like the dodc which
oversees superheroes currently and all
other enhanced individuals and of course
the GRC which is an international agency
overseen by the United Nations but
wakanda forever establishes new
political players Richard Shipp is
playing the new secretary of state A
fitting role for this actor since he's
best known for playing White House
communications director Toby Ziegler on
The West Wing but this also means that
Thaddeus Ross is no longer the Secretary
of State but there's likely a reason why
more on that in a bit but we now know
Val Valentina Liquors Fontaine Julia
Louis Dreyfus is the director of the CIA
which is a much more public role than
the shadowy Rogue that she seemed to
play in the Falcon the Winter Soldier
and in Black Widow the CIA director is
appointed by the president and approved
by the Senate and while the CIA director
is typically someone with a wide range
of experience and bipartisan respect
among the intelligence Community it does
remain a political appointee so this
ties Val close with the current U.S
president in the MCU who is president
ritzen played by German Mulroney we see
a brief shot of Mulroney as Ritson in
the secret Invasion trailer in which it
looks like his motorcade is being
attacked now in wakanda Forever
president ritzen is referenced both in a
news ticker and one of Anderson Cooper's
cameos and is referenced not by name in
a scene with the CIA director Val
Everett Ross in the Secretary of State
the secretary of state says the
president wants to take offensive action
against wakanda Val asks what kind of
offensive action and the Secretary of
State responds destabilization so while
Val feigns shock at invading wakanda she
later admits to Ross that she dreams of
U.S exclusive control over vibranium
Weaponry there are a number of reasons
why the U.S would want to control
vibranium but specifically I think the
reason president written and the CIA
director Val want to destabilize wakanda
is that it Remains the most powerful
Nation on Earth and they want Earth
overall to be less protected for an
alien infiltration Ritz and Val I think
are either squirrels themselves or are
likely targets for squirrel
impersonation but is big news is that
Harrison Ford has been cast as the new
Thunderbolt Ross names you after William
Hurt passed away and he's going to be
playing Ross in Captain America new
world order but in the past week there
are actually some uncovered reports of
his character description from scooper
Daniel rbk who claimed to have seen an
internal character description for us
that reads the former Lieutenant General
of the United States Army and Secretary
of State now president of the United
States using radiation siphon
transformed Ross into the red hole okay
Thunderbolt Ross Red Hulk theories have
been speculated by channels like ours
for years now so it's not surprising to
see these kinds of reports coming from
scoopers but what I find really
interesting about these rumors is that
Harrison Ford Thaddeus Ross could be the
president in New World Order which from
a casting perspective makes sense
Harrison Ford is a presidential figure
from roles like Air Force One and having
played Jack Ryan who did become
president at one point in time Clancy's
fictional universe but if it is true
that he is president that would mean
something will have to happen to Dermot
Mulroney president ritzen in secret
Invasion and Harrison Ford Thaddeus Ross
would have to be the current vice
president so there we go that's where
everything is right now now I like doing
things for myself like I make my own
breakfast from scratch every day but
what I can't make from scratch is coffee
every day instead I order from coffee
cult coffee cult is the closest you can
get to roasting your own coffee beans
without actually growing and roasting
your own Beans Coffee cold sources only
especially great arabica coffee beans
from all over the world they work
diligently with their Farmers to ensure
the best quality possible they inspect
every Bean so that they're never
roasting anything that's less than
excellent and speaking of roasting most
coffee companies don't roast their own
beans and when they do they roast them
in big batches and hope somebody orders
them before they lose that fresh roasted
flavor but not coffee cold coffee cold
only roasts their own beans but they
roast to order meaning that when you get
your coffee from coffee cold those beans
have been roasted fresh and let me tell
you God I just want to curl up next to
the window with the monkey this stuff
and coffee cult has a ton of different
roasts and blends so you can find the
perfect coffee for you lately I've been
feeling seasonal thanks to the holiday
blend it's the best coffee for the
holiday season it's caramelized full
body gives you a rich festive flavor
with notes of baker's chocolate brown
sugar and blueberry and a little
reindeer told me this is Santa's
favorite coffee if it's good enough for
him it's good enough for me and ho ho ho
what's this a cup of Jojo
um so get a bag for yourself duh but
also this makes a great gift send a bag
to the coffee lovers in your life who
are tired of getting scented candles and
gift cards from you every morning
they'll have some of the best coffee
that they've ever had and think of you
it's a no-brainer so whether you're
buying for yourself or for others go to
copycult.com and put in the promo code
new rockstars20 to get 20 off your order
order more than 50 worth of coffee and
you'll get free shipping too again
that's copycult.com and use the promo
code new rockstars20 for 20 off your
order that is I guess unless of course
there's some general election between
secret evasion and New World Order I
just think Ross is really a logical
choice of a vice presidential pick it
would explain why he's no longer
Secretary of State Ross has plenty of
military experience and a background
overseeing The Avengers being tough on
Avengers and it's the kind of hard ass
you'd like to have at the bottom of the
ticket I'm sorry my political strategy
brain is kicking in here I did study
political science and journalism in
college before becoming a professional
movie nerd but I think that's actually
going to help us in Phase five so again
the hierarchy president ritzen vice
president Thunderbolt Ross Secretary of
State Richard Schiff CIA director Val
ritson's gonna get removed somehow
during secret evasion may be exposed as
a scroll maybe resignation maybe
assassination by the Scrolls or maybe by
Val and then vice president Ross steps
up as president the hard-ass vet Law and
Order strong man who cracks down on
society in the aftermath of all this so
I think in Phase five Earth will be a
Battleground for at least two Shadow
factions the squirrel Empire who wants
to use Earth as a new home base to fight
off the Imperial cree and then the
Grassroots intelligencia Network we're
talking beyond the website from She-Hulk
a more Sinister and more dangerous
Society led by the leader returning a
new world order and may be powered by
residual Intel from Hydra in the Zola
algorithm and weapons technology
provided by oh I don't know Victor Von
Doom so in New World Order while Ross
remains scroll paranoid I think he's
going to be blinded from the real threat
closer to home from the Intelligentsia
who like in the comics will seek to
weaponize Thaddeus Ross into Red Hulk
which now pitching that for a movie
sounds pretty crazy but as She-Hulk
explored the legality of being a Hulk a
walking weapon of mass destruction and
Matt Murdock established at the sokovia
Accords were revealed the president
under U.S law is the one citizen for
whom it's debated whether or not they
have full legal immunity something you
might have read about in headlines for
the past few years Richard Nixon
infamously said when the pressure does
it that means it's not it's not illegal
in certain legal interpretations of the
Constitution terrifyingly back that up
yes in principle under U.S law no one
should be above the law but the U.S
justice department has these stupid
guidelines advising against
investigating a sitting U.S president
which is why when the president is
suspected of doing something illegal
they always have to appoint a special
prosecutor so really currently our
system relies on checks and balances
like impeachment from Congress relies on
courts and really it relies on a
president just bowing to political
pressure that's why Richard Nixon
resigned before he was actually
impeached but if a president just
ignores all that and if that president
has enough political supporters in
Congress who refuse to impeach him and
if the military backs of the president
we could have a constitutional crisis on
our hands that has never really been
tested in bring conditions really all is
to say when it comes to the MCU there
exists a hypothetical scenario where the
president and only the president could
become a Hulk and no one could legally
arrest him for that which is real fun
let me know your thoughts on all this
you can follow me on Tick Tock Instagram
and Twitter at eat hey boss follow me
Rockstar subscribe to new Rockstar some
more analysis of everything you love
thanks for watching bye
[Music]